tell us Rick how did you get the idea
for slacker quite different from
anything that we usually see here
slacker
I guess the original idea was the the
form of it the way that wouldn't be a
traditional narrative I guess it was a
really early idea I thought about it
probably five years before I actually
made the film it was one of those early
kind of radical ideas you have when
you're just get into something else
thinking like you're trying to break out
of that with everything that's come
before so I was just why couldn't you I
remember I was driving to Houston I was
like why can't you just make a film
where he just goes from character to
character and that could be a whole film
and I was watching a lot of experimental
films at the time thinking hi so it
started there but it took all those
years of thinking about how that might
work to make to make that work which is
I mean most people when they talk about
the film now it's it's in a I guess
sociological sort of way but analyze it
today yeah did more about the content
look for me it all started was the for
the formal kind of agenda the formal
aspects of the film the cinematic
qualities that was my initial impulse
the actual what happens in each scene
came down to probably my budget
limitations making it in my own
neighborhood here in Austin it was a
kind of film that I could make at that
time with no money it's kind of the I
don't know the poverty of the the film
itself kind of reflects the is
intertwined with the subject matter I
would say were you a film soon that's
time no I never went to film school
I just bought a super 8 camera and
started to just watched a million films
a friend a couple friends of mine and I
we started a Film Society we still run
here in Austin and the Austin Film yeah
yeah that's been going nine years now
that's a lot a lot of independent
filmmakers in town yeah we just had a
screening today in fact I just came from
so I'm real I'm as proud of the Film
Society is anything where were you know
doing Oshima and Godard retrospectives
and stuff like that so I was always my
whole life was just cinema and while I
was showing all these films and running
the arts organization I was also just
shooting a lot of film editing writing
and all that so it all kind of slacker
was the first big effort to kind of come
out of all that I'd done a super8
feature before then I spent two years on
is like a three thousand dollar budget
so grateful when did you actually start
doing slack or did you summer of 89
summers alive 89 we start shooting it
and if you have a complete script then
or did the script evolve as the shooting
trans model I had what I wanted for a
script I really don't like scripts
they're kind of they really limit you I
think in a lot of ways what I had was
just the structure what happens in each
scene structured from like the beginning
to the end because the way was
interlinked was very important it was
all about the structure for a film that
seems so structureless
in a way it's all about structure but
within that structure there's a lot of
freedom and I kind of approached the
film the same way too I knew like what
character I kind of wrote it all in
about a 24 hour period like what happens
ok this meat here you know they go here
this is what the scenes about this is
what happens I only had probably
dialogue for probably 30% of it before I
start showing it to people and then we
would cast people it was this big
casting search locally mostly non
professionals just people I thought kind
of embodied the essence of what I wanted
for that character and then just working
with them often I would type up the
sample dialogue before our first
rehearsal I just call it sample dialogue
and that was you know the structure of
the scene what it was about was all laid
out but then within that there was a lot
of freedom and a lot of that was to me
the most fun and satisfying point is
that why the so called acting doesn't
sound like acting is there they're
really just they brought their own
dialogue to the situation well you
already set up because it just seemed so
natural
no that's as a director that's what I
try to strive for even when I'm working
with professional actors or something
that's fully scripted I'm not so adamant
as a writer I always say the director in
me fires the writer you know before you
even start shooting and you know it's
just what whatever makes it seem real
and if that's the style of it to to seem
real you know certain words just aren't
in their vocabulary so ok let's make it
make sense and I think a lot of
directors work like that Altman's course
I stood Woody Allen even as great a
writer as he could still say oh just
putting your own words as long as it
means what you want it to mean you're
communicating what you want to
communicate and you just want to do it
in the most realistic way or at least I
do that that just seems to work but you
know the actors so many of them brought
so much to their parts you know when you
work in a
to me it was all about the making of it
you know we didn't really care never
thought really the film would get seen
very widely or anything it was just fun
to make it was like the summer art
project get some creative people in a
room together let's do this oh that's
funny oh that's a funny you know let's
make it work so by the time we were
shooting there was no Emperor improv you
know no that was going on it was all you
know by the time we were shooting it was
scripted we were very much exactly then
yeah I can't afford just to turn on a
camera and see what happens but it was
chill oh so naturally yes that was the
goal that was kind of the trick of the
film to make it meeting like a
documentary like hey just turn on the
camera and this happened but of course
like it doesn't work like that but they
find amateurs to be able to do with them
well because the professionals know
always yes I mean it was really amazing
I look back at that film like I didn't
see it for a couple years and I saw it
last year and I was like wow that was
really kind of had I known more we
wouldn't have even attempted that
because it's really tough to pull off a
four-minute take you know
non-professionals it was just the
atmosphere was so kind of right I think
for it that it seemed to work but this
is the big risk how'd you come up with a
different characters of different types
of people in the script huh um that's
that's always one of those tough
questions answered just people that I
mean things I had seen ideas I had I
really want to review this this morning
that you had a diary for several years
that every time you'd observe a strange
character strange behavior strange
dialogue we're seeing you jot it down
and it was sort of the encyclopedia for
typical writers journals I just write
down you know I'm always writing little
things so a lot of it happened verbatim
to me like when the lady is in the
coffee shop telling the yelling at the
guy you know you should never traumatize
a woman that that happened to me
verbatim
in every coffee shop in New York well
these things I didn't have to write down
the time I just remembered it well these
things I didn't have to write down the
time I just remembered it so this was a
good I think what you'd call a kitchen
sink movie where you could throw in all
kinds of stuff what about the anarchist
who claimed he fought in the Spanish
Civil War
Lewis Mackie yeah did did it was that
amazing very that was everybody yeah
yeah and actually a lot of that was at
about half this and was based on a
friend of mine who would
the short story with that character so
as I asked him was like hey you know
that character I really want to include
him in this in this movie but what
extent does that sort of set the stage
for the film and sort of the structure
and the aesthetic is laid out on that
opening and sets up that whole concept
of like parallel universes are just that
sort of thinking that thought kind of
creates for more that I really wanted
people thinking that well we're just
viewing these people but it could be
other people like everyone has a life
and we're going to see two minutes of
these hundred people's life just a weird
inner intersection but really I kind of
saw the movie as maybe like 50 movies
going on simultaneously and you're just
jumping from one to the next they're
kind of intertwined but if you look at
everyone's life as a movie that's
unfolding we're just getting a few
minutes you know at any at any time
there was something that struck me I've
only seen it once and that is that
although there are some exceptions most
of the characters they seem to people in
a plane in the characters they either
seem to be not as actors but I mean it
catches himself
they either seemed not to be listening
to each other or annoyed with what the
other person the main person that that
particular time is saying is they're
conscious I stay up here well I guess I
thought is this attempt at communication
I wasn't sure at that time people really
could communicate I wasn't sure if
people were listening to anything so I'd
always instruct the actor the typical
scene is one person doing all the
talking the other doing all the
listening 95% 5% usually that's the
typical scene it's not a hundred you
know um like me in the cab with the guy
so I was told to be as neutral as
possible I didn't want to put any
judgment on to the what they were saying
I want it to be you know if you have a
reason naturally the audience will
identify with the other character who's
listening so if they're sitting there
you know making weird faces or laughing
at him or even that puts a judgement on
to what that person saying I wanted it
to be like a direct communication in the
film really through the person talking
to the audience member without any you
know that's even the choice of like
camera lens or the way it was shot very
straightforward straight on in a
non-judgmental way I just like the idea
of the audience being able to do with
you know whatever they wished with that
information
saw the whole film is this kind of
alternate alternative information you
know unaccredited information that's
floating through society you know that
buzz of you know called conspiracy or
schizophrenia or whatever and some
people come out the movie says oh you
know they were really interesting other
people come out say oh they're all
insane or oh that's depressing or oh I
thought it was funnier you know they're
all valid I think in fact I was
interested this morning and seeing that
some of the early reviews of the film
indicated that the characters were
beatniks at the New York Times article
described on his college dropouts
eccentrics and neo Beaton a neo beaten
in Austin Texas and then that term Neil
beatnik was taken off is the term
beatnik appropriate and what is a slack
no no that I think it's I heard that neo
beatnik term first we started hearing
that and that was quickly replaced by
our own term slacker it kind of caught
up it's amazing how quick a word can
work its way into the culture so it
quickly
I never heard meet beatnik again and
surprisingly never heard hippie at all I
guess because their lack of like
political you know intent but it quickly
became generate Gen X twenty something
or slacker right depicted what is the
name workers and then what's the origin
other well you I mean it's a real word
you know I mean it's in the dictionary
used a lot around World War One World
War one
yeah somebody I didn't want to go to the
drag war yeah right it's someone
avoiding the draft or duties or
responsibilities and it you know it's
kind of a negative word you would call
someone that and it it just kind of that
wasn't our original name of the film
even it just kind of came up during
production we started calling each other
slackers and it was kind of a joke at
first we didn't think it was the right
name and eventually it seemed like the
only name for the film in fact more
people know the term now than have ever
seen the movie and they use it in a kind
of negative way I think when people I
mean President Clinton at a graduation
in UCLA tells the whole graduating class
oh you're not a generation of slackers
your generation of seekers I'm going
look that's what I pay but I were done
what I think slackers are you know but I
mean he probably shouldn't be using that
knowing that it's a draft dodger
well these slackers slackers in your
movie are they different from the way I
don't want to call them hippies but
people in Austin in the 60s and 70s who
could lead that alternative and kind of
drop out lifestyle or a political
activist lifestyle right because of
prosperity they could work half a day
mm-hmm at a nothing job and have enough
money so they still live but these
people were really hard up against it in
difficult times are these still slackers
yeah I always said I mean it's that
certain percentage of people live on the
margins of our society who have always
been I mean the entire post-world War
two period I would say has always had
that would you want to call Phoenix
hippies you know whatever I just think
they had kind of fallen out of media
they had been represented much in the
media in the last 15 years or so
certainly since you know the reagan-bush
era had kind of forgotten about these
people but I think they've always
existed and I think the backdrop changes
this the social the political the
economic backdrop changes but they're
always going to be people on the margins
looking for not satisfied with what
usually young people college age or
older who not satisfied with what
they've you know although age really has
nothing to do with it it's anyone who's
just looking for I would say a realm of
activity that corresponds with what they
wanted you know their desire so they're
seeking that or they've dropped that out
of kind of consumer culture none of
these people have jobs we're only around
them for a few minutes so who knows I
would say a lot of them you know they
have jobs but the main point I want to
stress that their jobs weren't their
whole life that's not how they define
themselves oh I'm a waitress though I'm
a you know wasn't that it was all I'm
just a person or I'm a musician I'm a
writer I'm a filmmaker or whatever
that's how it they're just a thinking
person they're not a you know a worker I
think one of them says well I live bad
but I don't worry they don't have to
work to do it but mainly badly at least
I don't have to there was applause
usually yeah but there was I think
slacker in a personal way depicts
Texas and the kind of an 80s Texas thing
that's it's not really the same right
now five years later
it's that's it's a different situation
rents were cheaper than I think there
was that whole Depression era and I kind
of liked that that energy then was kind
of there was something good about it and
we were all kind of on that same level
but these are people who dropped out but
yeah but there are other people who live
perhaps same type of same type of life
as far as economics but they also spend
a lot of time in political activism so
in a sense they're slackers living in
that margin but they are activists at
the same time for as these don't do you
make a distinction between those types
of people or not really I just think
anyone can find their cause whether it's
their own art or whatever they're doing
or I wouldn't even go forward to say a
lot of the people in slack aren't
politically active I mean like I said
we're only with him a few minutes some
of them were spouting off stuff I would
think that they would take it when the
situation arose they would take it to
whatever right you know whatever they
felt correct about doing they're
certainly politically obsessed there's
all the talk about the JFK assassination
or different conspiracy theories about
the US but the point that I wanted to
pursue with you is that as I travel
around the United States I have a lot of
interaction with young people and your
generation and even younger that have
just responded to this incredibly it's
almost like it's a generational anthem
for them you know you're in the right
place at the right time or the wrong
place at the wrong time they kind of
captured some feeling that was in the
air I don't know
I've heard that slackers has become even
internationally famous and as a kind of
a cult if the word the word translated
really quickly the word and what they
took as the lifestyle or the surface
representation of it translated and went
to Europe rather quickly I mean they're
still writing articles and you know in
Europe about this genetics slacker thing
but I mean you know most of them haven't
seen the movie they haven't read the
book Generation X well then of course it
here locally you scared the hell out of
the Austen why they call those people
down there who run the city gate down so
see how often city council they were
afraid the people are going to see this
as slackers from
over the country and even maybe the
world we're going to stream them to us
well they did we got blamed in the
Dawson american-statesman it was somehow
a Sunday cover story about homeless
teenagers a lot there was a big influx
of homeless teenagers into Austin and
some sergeant with the police force or
somebody said it was because they all
saw slacker and thought this would be a
good place to come hang out you see it
ever used in a negative way once again
you see it ever between the slackers
like in your film and actual homeless
yeah young home yeah there's there's a
big there's a big difference I mean
these people are for the most part in
and around the college environment it's
kind of by choice it's not economic you
know they're not deprived in that way
although I mean economic opportunities
don't exist for them probably in the
same way I think that's what back to
your question if people really related
to it was kind of that sense of there's
really nothing for you out there why go
through school try to get the good job
make the great grades and then you
realize well there's a telemarketing job
waiting for you or something like that
the whole promise that corporate America
had everyone believing I think in the
50s 60s 70s that the reality of that
isn't isn't so great or that this
generation saw so much dissatisfaction
in the previous generation you know but
the whole yuppie thing didn't seem to go
anywhere and these people seem not very
happy so it probably a moment in history
where no one really knew where to put
their energy like do you go on the
career tenure track and then that
doesn't look too appealing and then well
my my band's not getting signed by
anymore you know it's just so you just
you're kind of caught you know I think
that's what I would really wanted to
depict that that kind of feeling of you
know it's just really of the moment it's
it's our communication here rather than
any anticipation of some better world or
that we can affect some change maybe
there was that disaffected feeling that
other generations of fell just that hey
you know maybe you don't like what your
what your country is you know currently
doing or what you're told you should be
striving for so
yeah up out the the thought I had this
morning was this is a generation that
comes after the hippies and the
generation of the 60s but it also comes
after the yuppies and it's a generation
that basically has to pay for the orgies
in the 1980s so we have the me
generation the me generation but also
the Reagan dad oh you're shrinking job
possibilities the just general prett
takeover mentality corporate like over a
job economic insecurities etc so there
isn't the future for this generation
that there was for previous generations
so what can you do other than live in
the moment I see the same thing with
beavis and butt-head is sort of evidence
that particularly working-class youth
without education have no future
whatsoever all they could do is watch
heavy-metal TV and go out trash things
so in this sense it's an accurate
sociological depicts yeah that's my next
movie there's a question I want to ask
you is such a brilliant statement I
think people are saying well kids are
apathetic nowadays and there's a
wonderful statement and that you have in
one of your characters says withdrawing
and disgust it's not the same as being
after that epithet thats what our
society never responds to her never let
you argue it's like you have to accept
the consumer culture Coke or Pepsi
Democrat or Republican you know
Longhorns are or Sooners or you know
whatever the game is and if you step
outside and say neither you know that's
what they don't no one can believe it
when you say it's if the question really
is what to buy not whether to buy or not
it's as soon as you go whether to buy or
not you can go hey I can live without
all this stuff let me live in my little
cheap apartment let me spend let me work
two shifts a week as a waiter and
support myself and let me not buy a new
car not buy new clothes not go out to
eat every night then I can spend all my
time reading or watching movies or
playing my guitar or writing or whatever
someone might truly feel better doing
with their time I mean I think that you
know society really doesn't want people
doing that doesn't any productive
is this way the statement you were
making when that one character said
everything you make is part of your
death every why do you produce as if
your idea well yeah I mean that's that's
a little harsh but let's do that I like
that beautiful statement yeah yeah Rick
I have a question about the statement
you're making with the end of the film
in an interview with Olli Hosseini that
was published in new state of New York
when it opened in New York you put a
very positive gloss on the ending there
was sort of a celebration of day-to-day
life that everyone's life was worthy of
cinema that's the scene where look at it
and go well what was I think I was
wondering if people do communicate I
think when I think of that kind of
communication I think that there's a
delayed reaction like when that person
you think is a little you know that
crazy person approaches you and starts
talking about a paranoid conspiracy rant
your first impulse as a society members
usually like okay are they dangerous do
they have a gun or they can attack me
you're defensive in a movie you can sit
there and watch that you're safe I
really wanted people to concentrate on
the information if the character in the
movie next to them doesn't get that or
think about it in your own life you get
a lot of it in a delayed way you know
after that situations over in your life
maybe the next morning you wake up
thinking you know what they were saying
there was pretty interesting or it makes
sense you know the film really depicts
no immediate connections are very few
the connections I think come later
just like the closure of the movie comes
later I mean you have to create it like
your lives don't have good closure our
lives don't have these perfect narrative
structure structures everything doesn't
fall into place neatly that's why I like
the ending to me it's kind of a new
beginning it's just on a film level it's
destroying the medium you know in a way
it's I like that for me that was an
early film impulse to kind of attack the
medium you're working in physically to
try to reinvent something I think that's
important you see that in all all arts
people kind of attack it you know look
at you know painting in different
different periods or people get kind of
violent with their own look at punk you
know different music at different times
attacking it but yet still using yeah
yeah actually you're attacking for
instance in your case the Hollywood
form from making a movie to make a
different kind of movie and on that
communication theme I saw it not only
about communication or disk at non
communication but also connection and
disconnection in other words some of the
people were connected with each other
and others seem to be just totally
disconnected from everything living in
their own worlds but the one thing they
all had in common it seemed to me they
were immersed in media culture that all
of the characters reference points
through the media whether it was
scooby-doo and correct some other
cartoon character as a source of
philosophy or Madonna and her pap smear
or whatever the the source of media
culture
it just seemed ubiquitous right I mean I
saw the whole movie is kind of second
door resources all these people had not
its most typify din the JFK
assassination guy he's not he's too
young to remember the assassination he
wasn't there or if maybe he was one year
old at the most he's obsessed with the
media representation he's talking about
books about he's obsessed with books
about the fascination enuf removed where
so many of the characters are really
removed from that initial impulse
they're you know like the Madonna pap
smear I mean it's so removed from the
essence of the original subject but I
mean I think that's the world we're
living in you know I had to question
that about myself I mean the guy who
says he's upset has all the TVs and a TV
backpack and talking about he had seems
this violent act but he missed the knife
and he trusts these he trusts his TV's
more that really happened to me I saw a
stabbing on a subway in New York I
didn't see the stabbing of course I saw
the aftermath some police the blood
looked very strange and I had to realize
well gosh I'm you know I've seen what 25
thousand murders probably by this age on
television but this is the first one
I've probably seen in real life and it
looks really didn't look real so like
well that's think of all your thoughts
about saying nature lions you know
rhinoceros is heavier seen them in real
life outside of zoos know most of us
haven't been on safaris in Africa but
yet we feel we have a complete knowledge
of this but it's all from you know media
media I mean that's just I'm not saying
that's a bad thing I think that's good
300 years ago you would just maybe read
books and see some pictures you wouldn't
even now we feel like we have you know
we have a relation with it so I'm not
good or bad I think that's just it does
a virus that's the world we're living in
so you know you got to go with it and
what I did like about the character with
you know he had his own project going
with the guy with all the TVs and that
he's trying to take all that and he says
instead of us working for it let's let's
make let's make it work for us
you know let's make it you know let's
use this and for our own ends you know
well invent ourselves the slacker was
obviously very successful in the ways
that we talked about it made 1.3 million
dollars which is pretty good for
independent film it became a cult
favorite it's been discussed
sociologically and countless articles
making you sort of the spokesperson or a
spokesperson for your generation and it
also caught the attention of Hollywood's
your second film Dazed and Confused was
financed by Hollywood slacker was was
not a calling card film it's not like
from USC grad student film like hey this
I want to get a job in industry I mean I
tried to make you know a film that would
alienate that establishment as much as
you possibly could but surprisingly I
mean I learned this about Hollywood that
it's not a moral entity they don't
really have an agenda other than create
and provide entertainment you know honey
for the people and money as all it is is
money and I had an idea for my next film
that sounded like you know is a teenage
rock and roll movie took place in the
70s and it just had that kind of they're
like oh that sounds interesting I mean
some guy they called me you know I
didn't get an agent go shut shipping
this around you know shopping it around
to to try to sell this thing it was like
some guy had heard that through an
interview I did I said I wanted to do
this teenage movie got a call from a guy
Universal says yeah it tells condition
we saw slacker but I mean it's he took
hearing what you wanted to do next not
the kind of film we'd uh you know but it
was funny I mean it was weird but it's
kind of funny plus you did it on five
figures right right that's what really
what really qualified me that a I'd
finished a film
that qualifies you as a filmmaker then I
had made a film that it actually made
some money for somebody that that put me
up another notch so it's like well
Hollywood's always been open for ideas
that's what's kind of neat about that as
an industry
I mean they've always taken in
immigrants people from all over you know
culture hey if you can provide that that
entertainment that makes money you
qualify so it's amazingly open in that
way and same with the ideas there's no
there's less an ideological agenda as
much as there is just an entertainment
money agenda so I kind of found a little
niche in there that it was a low-budget
film I mean the typical Hollywood film
these days the budgets is almost 30
million dollars for your average
Hollywood film and days was about six
so it was low-budget I didn't have to
get a lot of stars and we just kind of
it looked entertaining enough so I felt
I kind of found my niche there and was
able to you know get that film made bite
the hand that fed me sort of and get
that film made in in this system so but
I mean I don't know though I think it
was an entertaining you know kind of a
fun it was the fun teenage rock and roll
movie that I wanted to make you know to
me it was very critical but of that
world how do you compare that stratum of
youth with the slacker stratum that you
did you see connections between bunch of
different ages you know days was ages 14
through 17 slacker is 22 on probably 20
22 on so I would say they're kind of the
same characters a lot of them just they
haven't read as much you know it's
they're less they haven't got that next
they haven't got all their secondary
sources in order yet it's also a
different period it's 1976 right
graduation day in 76 once again in
Austin Texas so it's coming after the
1960s is closer to the 60s you have some
sort of 60s type attitudes and
characters in the movies including some
of the teachers that's right right come
on I went up at the 68 convention if you
listen closely right talking about being
it right like that convention so it's
sort of a different era and I guess this
race is also the question of
autobiography since you yourself I take
it went to high school in the nineteen
sounds of freshman in high school in
yeah and so to some extent is this
autobiographical or its you dealing with
yours very calm very autobiographical
just like slacker I don't know if it's
autobiographical I mean I filmed it in
my own house that's my neighborhood
these are people I know for the most
part I'd say it's more personal than
autobiographical were days looking back
you know to a previous time I mean that
was more autobiographical well nowadays
and confused had started with the
seniors of 76197 thanks Ryan
actually it's juniors and freshmen
juniors the seniors are off on a truck
it's people the oldest people in the
movie will be seniors the next year yeah
okay but and then the people in slacker
are from what late mid mid late 80s um
where we shot in 89 89 okay so it's
conceivable that some of those people
who were in or that is chronologically
yeah they would be the older could
become a slackers later sure they are
see did you make any connections when I
people asked me like what happened all
these bills there well a lot of them
they found they went to college and they
found out the 80s didn't really have
much to offer them and they you know
they drifted to the margins and who
knows what they're doing I know what I
did what was all those things I dropped
out I didn't work I you know did my own
thing I think a lot of people did them
so what extent do you see yourself as
sort of a regional filmmaker what sort
of the function of Texas in your film
your life yeah well it's a big part I
grew up here I grew up in both Houston
and Huntsville Texas which is kind of a
setting for days I wouldn't say it's
shot I wouldn't say Dazed is set in
Austin it's more of in a suburban town
near a big city you know like at least
40 miles from a big city kind of
suburbia
to me that was Huntsville where I spent
some crucial years but regional I don't
know I just I feel lucky to have been
able to stay here and make movies that
means a lot to me because I always
wanted to depict that other part of
Texas that you know most you know when
people think of Texas obviously they
think of cowboys and hats and horses and
oil and and all these things but that
wasn't my Texas you know Houston's what
the third largest city in the country I
grew up on cement you know in freeways
just like everybody
yes so it was kind of I felt my right or
privilege or luck to be able to show a
different kind of Texas than most people
seeing and people were almost offended
like really people in Austin because I
mean slacker you know had a lot of a lot
of thoughts a lot of ideas it's like hmm
ideas can come out of you know what they
consider the sticks it's like yeah well
sure
open your eyes leave Manhattan Island
you'll find out there's a big country
out there and people I mean we grew up
with that kind of inbred inferiority
complex just growing up in Texas that
we're just taught by the media and
everyone that well people there they're
just smarter than you are they just are
they know more their wives are they're
smarter and it's not until you actually
go there and hang out that you realize
well they're not any smarter than
anybody else no I had a person in Boston
once tell me you do a program out in
Austin how do you edit it what in the
world can you find in Austin Texas that
would be of anything right I mean I've
been in Hollywood I want to shoot in
Austin like me how will you doing I mean
where will you edit where were you you
know they just really they think it's
this Prairie you know the little
tumbleweed and a little you know so
actually the whole United States is
subject to the same cultural influences
and likewise having big state
universities like the University of
Texas which is every bit as good if not
better than the University of
Massachusetts or many California state
universities there is not quite the
provincial ISM that you found at one
time this is sort of a function all
right let me that's the whole global
village I go to village it's happened
and we're united in our culture I think
certainly uh that's what days kind of
represented to me I mean you got these
living in a shitty little town in East
Texas you have these kids who are tapped
into kind of a national culture it's
really a music culture kind of a drug
culture just a hip cool culture of their
own making I mean you know they've
created their own little culture in
within a bigger culture and the only way
they even know to do that is just the
cues they're getting through the media
through radio television music music
being music being the foundation so what
extent was that an actual fad yeah
that's very high school
I could have never thought that up on my
own that wouldn't be something I would
know that actually happened and you
still see it not so much at a high
school level but you see I think at
sororities and fraternities they have
their own everyone has their own version
of initiation ritual whether it's just
general harassment I mean that what was
strange about that at the time and this
only hits you years later second that
was very strange just how regimented and
organized it was with the you know the
whole town kind of turning and turning
another way and letting it go on so it
all really happened hmm you know some
kind when I saw it it seemed like an
overlay of different cultures of 50s
cultures with a bit of the 60s culture
on the other hand I came to Austin in 73
and at least the University and the
political culture and the people I saw
wasn't like this at all and when my son
graduated from high school in 82 in
Austin and this wasn't some very much
like Dazed and Confused it seemed like
it was kind of but Dazed and Confused
seem more like the 50s when I grew up in
the late 40s and early 50s with an
overlay of pot smoking and something
like that you could take the last
picture show and just add rock and roll
and pot smoking and you have the same
it's just suburbia teenagers trapped in
wherever their parents live so this I
asked your friend of mine I said now
this you grew up in this era they said
that this really was this reflect your
experience he said yeah a small town it
was yeah it was it wasn't just like I
said well wasn't what I saw with or
without a hazing initiation yeah
without the hazing distillation
signatures I think teenagers have been
doing the same thing since you know once
again post-war I mean you know rebel
without a cause I mean they're getting
in chicken fights and erases and you
know just teenagers have always been
kind of miserable and oppressed their
parents oppressing their schools
oppressing their local environment
oppresses them there's no place to go
well they press your misra yeah and so
you naturally you take it out on each
other you threaten each other's lives
basically I mean teenagers will will
risk their lives to be affected by
anything
to have something going on so it's kind
of death-defying behavior it's kind of
insane it's amazing anyone survives
those years but you know I think it's
just people you can oppress I mean by
the time you're 14 you you know you have
this raging individuality that wants to
express itself and if the culture around
you everything around you is not letting
you do that it's going to you know
you're going to break windows you're
going to cause trouble you guys are
going to get in fights I wanted to
depict all that because that was you
know it's whatever immigrant amateur
anthropology but you know that's just
kind of so wanted to show that world so
teenage culture you're saying really
hadn't change that much I don't think
route over the generations revel without
a cause when they get into college then
is that where some change occurs I mean
obviously from the 50s the college
people in the 50s are so different from
the 60s and the hippies and the nd the
dope smoking and the drugs and the
political activity was so completely
different from my experience in the 50s
and so does the bigger changes occur
then when you when you get out of I
think so yeah you just you know like
rite of passage you have to get away
from your parents before you can move on
and really start thinking for yourself
and you know but it's not just the
parents it's a whole environment that
whole small town environment or wherever
just that high school environment the
high school invited indoctrination of
our public education I mean that's
that's the biggest thing to repel
against and try to you know and to me it
just represented I mean personally it
was I didn't
I felt I didn't learn anything until I
got out of school altogether till I got
managed to get through high school and
whatever college I went to and really
started I didn't know who I was even
until I started really kind of
functioning on my own reading what I
wanted to read watching what I wanted to
watch and you know going in that
direction likes a long time to the the
high school I think that you presented
was really as a trap the sports being a
trap phasing in the rituals the drinking
and the drugs is something some part of
escape from the trap
I thought transcend but also a just
still being kept up in that environment
at the end you have your main character
driving off
as sort of an escape from the normality
or banality of this environment right I
mean it's kind of similar to the end of
slacker I think in that way that they
they break out of their oppressive
environment just to you know something
as mundane is going to get Aerosmith
Tickets but yet they're they're leaving
town they've been up all night and no no
I saw that it's positive even you know
there's still smoking pot and driving
and been up all night maybe it's even
dangerous but you know I like that I
like the spirit of that I mean I saw
dazed if you look at it above there's
even a shot after the fight at the party
that's from the moon tower up high above
them and I just saw the film kind of
from above it's a circle they're all
trapped in where they're riding around
from the pool hall to the burger joint
it's like a circle and you know they're
all interconnected and they're all going
in circles but to like break out of that
circle that's what the ending
represented to me do you think that the
this is a small small town you think
that the kids in larger towns and bigger
cities were experienced the same type of
thing there's that much time swinging I
think a real similar thing cuz I went to
school in both in a town that had 20,000
people and then I and also went to high
school in Houston you know a large city
and it was it was similar there were
more things to do in the bigger city you
know but the essence of it was the same
on a Friday or Saturday night it's like
let's do something well what do we do
okay
what's a rails doing oh they're hanging
out in the parking lot somewhere oh the
school parking lot or the 7-eleven
parking lot or it's you're in a group
and there's just kind of like well
what's going to happen I mean you're
just waiting for something to happen
it's like you're waiting for your life
to start you're waiting you know when
does it begin that's even have
characters talk about that it's like
aren't you tired of everything being a
preamble to you know yeah they said all
we do is prepare for the future right
but what are we preparing for I'm just
saying we're gonna go I'm gonna drive
around you just do some how
yeah you know you right man I'm just
gonna you know get drunk baby no I'm
serious man we should be up for anything
I know we are but what I mean God don't
you ever feel like everything we do and
everything we've been taught is just to
service the future I know it's like it's
all preparation right but what are we
preparing yourselves for dad I wanted to
show that like the the seeds are there
for a lot of dissatisfaction have
already been planted in you know a third
to a half of the cast will go on and
rebell and probably do something
interesting what was the reaction
today's is confused I mean particularly
after slacker being such a different
thing in a lot of ways I was accepting
well critically very well I mean it got
better much better reviews even in
slacker then audience it quickly became
a cult film the studio the attitude of
the studio was I think they thought I'd
kind of pulled one over on him they
didn't really like to move that much it
wasn't quite Wayne's world it wasn't
quite American Graffiti or all the ideas
they had for it there was - it was a
little too brutal too much cussing too
much a lot use I think that was they
just kind of went yeah right I think I
was a initial sort of Hollywood and
studio response I remember seeing some
CNN Clips right when it was released
right they were afraid there was two Pro
drugs right I was promoting drugs
whereas you were just depicting right
environment you again you were showing
this is part of the trap you weren't
exactly there to me the alcohol and in
all it was it was pot smoking but to me
that was just a symbol of their
rebellion
you know kids are going to do that just
when when they're oppressed they're
going to rebell in any way they can
and that's I mean that was personal to
me I remember smoking pot in high school
and just going I don't ever remember
really craving being high or drunk it
was just like it was fun to do in a
bonding sort of way it was like all of
us kind of flipping off the
establishment in our own little way - no
you were officially breaking the law you
weren't supposed to be doing this it was
just fun dazed and confused when it came
out was that the women characters were
underdeveloped and I saw it again last
night true for the second time and all
of the male characters had a pretty
clear profile where I could
scribe you know what they looked like
what they did what their characters were
and with the women characters I would be
a little hard pressed to sort of
differentiate them with the exception of
the redhead that was given a little more
was is this just a statement that women
were pretty much the same or how did you
respond to say a feminist critique of
that sort oh well yeah I did hear that
some I think that just personally
speaking once again I remember all the
parties and the thrust of the activity
that the driving around all that was
pretty male it's pretty much a teenage
male perspective because in my opinion
males kind of have this raging energy at
that time and they do kind of override
if you listen closely the women are
really more interesting characters even
the little bits of dialogue you get in
the girls bathroom there's a lot more
interesting thought going on there
there's a lot more interesting thought
going on there it's just the film
doesn't really go in that area in that
way that it's more this kind of party
thrust the it's very much a teenage boy
kind of thing public environment yeah
viral the hazing it was sports which is
yeah I mean if accommodated by sports
cars parties pool halls fights yeah
fights it's very very teenage it is a
male male and yeah the women have their
own culture but it's kind of in there in
this position where they're if they want
to be around the guys which they do they
have to kind of go to the games and kind
of hang out and do what the guys or at
least be in that you know I always
admired the women who said you know
that's such [ __ ] I'm just gonna go
off with fuel usually they're older
friends and do something much more
grown-up a lot of the women that age or
seems so much more mature and growing up
than than the guys well they are kind of
insane they are from about eight or nine
years on oh it's pretty funny so yeah I
mean but that was kind of always the
design of the movie I mean there was
probably more and that I shot a lot of
it just got cut out and in a way too so
it was a combination were you able at to
edit completely have complete control
over that like he did so much like yeah
um we were editing on the universal lot
I was lucky I didn't you know they never
came in the editing room you have to
have these previews so I mean I got my
cut they never
never like took the film away from me or
anything I was very lucky I mean still
it's irritating it was irritating for me
just to have to listen to a lot of
opinions by people I didn't respect that
was the weird thing and they thought I
was being difficult but and and I wasn't
really happy just even having to kind of
go through that political hierarchy
ringer that is a studio previews
listening to audience members talk about
the film listening to a lot of
suggestions about how maybe you should
reshoot the ending and give it a little
more of this or do a voiceover too and
getting all the things that I would
never do to the film and it was just
tough to kind of deflect all that but I
did so basically you had control yeah
the shooting the editing sure and
casting also on script
yeah I was amazing I think it was just
because of our low budget and that I
really was determined or had a really
strong idea for the film or you know
idea I think if you go in and you're
like you're doing a film that someone
else's script and it's a say a you know
psychological thriller and has really
definite plots plot points and yeah
you're kind of putting yourself at the
mercy of a studio that oh the ending
doesn't work we need to reshoot it where
she kills him like well you got to do it
to make the film successful so this
thing was so personal there was really
no other way for it to go except my own
personal vision so I mean while I was at
Universal they were taking literally
taking films away from some pretty
big-name directors there while I was at
there so I felt really lucky to not
because that's what Hollywood does I
mean it is all about this so if this
product you're creating suddenly that's
in jeopardy they're going to do whatever
they have to do to make that the more
marketable film so it's just it turns
into a political game and I just kind of
had them convinced or people liked the
film I was always lucky that the film
always worked had the film had a lot of
problems and not worked with audiences
you know I could have been in you know a
bad situation and it did get got out
alive you know so you survived clearly I
had trouble with you know the music
there was a lot of just you know like I
said irritants you have to deal with but
but nothing major drug drove and for a
first film with the studio I was really
lucky that well mainly I didn't care I
wouldn't be in a careerist I mean where
they get you is like well I want to do
another film
I want to so I didn't care if I ever
worked with them again so that put me a
much better position because I mean the
way they think of filmmakers oh well
we'll go to Sundance next year and find
another new filmmaker you're nothing
special I'm like well neither are you
there's a lot more of you meaning studio
executives that kind of people then
there are me so I was confident that I
could get other films made at other
places and sure enough I ended up at a
better situation even well Ricky you
seem to have survived your Hollywood
experience Dazed and Confused did well
got good reviews circulated around
became a cult film and evidently you're
able to make another film before sunrise
can you tell how that idea came about
and how you finance the made the film
yeah I feel once again lucky to be able
to like I'm on a lucky streak here that
I'm just lucky to make these really
personal films but uh it was after days
came out I kind of got lucky there that
although it wasn't like a big you know
blockbuster or anything it uh people in
the studio's liked it because they're
all like my age sometimes a little older
sometimes younger even yeah the people
who run Hollywood it's a young world
it's a young world I was meeting people
who are younger than me that were like
presidents of production at major
studios they're like they were like hey
man that was my high school that so I
kind of I felt like their guy generation
yeah it was like hey man solidarity you
yeah they felt very connected to me so I
went around and met all the studios cuz
they hadn't really done the Hollywood
thing I hadn't really met I just had my
first phone call from Universal I went
and did that phone with them so I didn't
really know the business so it's weird
going around to all the studios and
meeting all and they are all very nice
you know very smart don't people are
really you know generally very educated
very smart kind of passionate about
films yeah there is about a soap yeah
it's wrote and vicious in the big sense
it is all that player stuff the Altman
film that's all true but individually
they're all like great people very smart
very but it's just it's that world kind
of closes in and makes people act in a
really vicious kind of crazy way and
I've experienced that I did a little bit
on Days with our you know the mostly in
the music related aspects to it was
pretty pretty vicious pretty bad but um
so anyway I went around and met met
everyone and then we're just talking
about some films I wanted to do I have
some other scripts and things and I just
kind of found a home at Castle Rock
which is they're an independent company
there's five partners
Rob Reiner is one of them they've done
really big films his films are ordered
stuff like inline a fire big very
successful company and they're kind of
like a studio that they financed their
own films
but they're kind of a mini major so I
just I really like them and they said
they would do this next film which is
even it's smaller the budgets half the
size of days it's about less than three
million actually so for them it was I
think they just kind of gave me this
film's like okay yeah sure we like the
idea go ahead and do it they're hoping
I'll do other films with them so they
kind of gave me this film which is it's
great but they really like the film I
think it's a it has elements that
slacker and dazed don't have it I think
it's a little bit more of a story and
it's a male/female story too so it's
kind of a romance my own version of a
romance I guess what's the concept of it
um it's like boy meets girl on it it's
been it was a really good experience
very small small crew two people very
different I mean I made these two big
ensemble movies but you know I like the
film I really like the experience of
working with the two actors Julie Delpy
French actress she's really wonderful
and Ethan Hawke plays the American guys
how did you ride it or did you have a
rock yeah yeah it was an old idea I
actually wrote it with a friend of mine
a woman Kim Cruzan when I sat down to
write the script same thing like slacker
I thought about it five years took a lot
of notes and then when I sat down to
write the script I really wanted since
you know I think it was very important
for the film to have a very strong
female voice so I got a friend of mine
who I uh you know I just really liked
the way she thought and she had never
written a screenplay or anything but I
was like here let's let's work on this
so we threw out a lot of ideas and I
really liked what we came up with and
then in the rehearsal process once again
I opened it up and we took it to another
level with the actors themselves they
had a lot to bring to it and it's very
very creative very very fun project I
don't know you know what kind of film
it'll be ultimately but uh I think you
get in trouble as a filmmaker if you
think care about too much about how what
happens to the film after you're
finished with it because you can't
control any of that really it's got to
be happy I really enjoyed the process of
working on it had a really good creative
time
the Hollywood industry is so much more
open and complex and what it used to be
when I did the the big studios and they
didn't have independence all right where
they were really struggling and I had to
get their money from Wall Street has
that changed I think Holly was gonna in
a good place I don't really get into
Hollywood bashing too much because I
mean you can cuz like just like you can
with any arts I mean most stuff that
comes out isn't very good you know most
books publisher aren't very good most
films that come out aren't very good you
know so it's an underachievement on one
level but it's the system's open enough
I think in an independent way the way
it's financed now it's kind of own you
know multinational there's a lot the
distribution is more interesting it used
to be just studios you know these five
studios or whatever and there wasn't an
independent network there was drive-ins
and like really grade B movies yeah kind
of driving things that was independent
and then there was big studio where now
there's a middle ground that that's you
know you can do a lower budget movie and
it can find an audience or they can make
money distributing it at a small level
where it used to be they could only make
money with their big films now they
figure out they can make less but it's
money with smaller films so I like to
think that I'm at that niche in there
thinking that that's that's a
comfortable place because the mistakes
are really much lower with video cable
world sales that they're not going to
lose money that was the point that I was
going to make that with cable and all
the pay TV channels right well it's just
movie channels as well as VCRs video
rental and international cable and
rather sales they can make money off of
a movie without even releasing it and on
odors I know so this does open up to as
you say a more varied product but also
Hollywood if they'll make money even you
know minor money they'll still find you
because they're making money and Spike
Lee for instance like you started off in
a very low-budget
self financed film she's got to have it
right and then went up and up because he
was right money and it wasn't because
they really wanted to show the
african-american
to America they don't care about that
but the african-american experience that
he showed made money so they'll continue
to fund it save your money and all did
you have did you have to hire an agent
to somebody who would look out after
your interests so that you wouldn't be
taking advantage of and skinned by all
the sharpest out there on the west coast
have a good New York entertainment
lawyer
is that that's who my person has been
but I recently started working with an
agency to just because I realized if I
was going to be the outsider in
Hollywood which I am I still live in
Austin I don't go out there much that I
do it's good to have someone out there
kind of representing you if you if you
want to be able to you know play that
game so I'm kind of doing this dance one
foot in one foot out so so far so good
what about publicity do you have a
publicity agent or do you just expect
the studio for instance and dazed and
confused to publicize it yeah it's kind
of in-house they you know they all have
their own publicity wing and they do
that so the only time I do publicity is
you know when the film's coming out you
end up doing a lot so you don't have to
worry about that you basically just do
what they tell you in the sense you're
good interviews and right it's kind of
battle with the film right whatever is I
still go to a festival do some
interviews do phone interviews every
near the release it's pretty insane
really I mean you do these junkets
you've seen those where the you sit in a
chair and they do these seven-minute
interviews and you might do 10 of those
in a row and then you go sit at a table
with all these people and it's just this
kind of oh this very strange system of
you feel like you're just going down an
assembly line like you just shake hands
with this person they ask you the same 7
questions I mean at you know you live in
some small town and your local film
critic is interviewing Arnold
Schwarzenegger oh my god but what he's
done is flown to New York he sat in a
chair for seven minutes two camera
people you know they shoot him they get
a reverse shot of him they do it package
it so he goes through the thing the
Hanuma tape here show that's on your
local morning show and it's just it's
the publicity machine it's pretty
amazing to see that work it's kind of
you know it's evil I used to think oh
god this is so man you it's like
manufactured you know I grew really
cynical just to see like
oh you know whether it's an interview
with you or whether you're on TV it's
just like guy you're just filler you
know between ads you know that's been my
attitude your sound your sound by your
this your that it gets really offensive
so I've had to dodge a lot of that like
Kurt Cobain dies you know I get a call
from ABC they want to interview me you
know just what is I like no way you know
if you said yes to everything you know
like I don't want to participate in that
well now you've made your third film
what do you have coming up that oh it's
the well dry writing writing got a got a
couple scripts I'd like to do just
trying to get in a position to do the
next one um yeah it seems to gotten
easier for me to to get the next project
going I mean there was a real lag time
after slacker getting slacker scene by
the time it came out I mean I lost I
felt a year there somewhere but now I
can kind of go from one project to the
next so I'm hoping to be in production
again this summer on a another Texas
story it's a book I option last spring
just came out by small Austin Stone
House press whatever the small press
here called the Newton boys it's about
these bank robbers in the early 20s
true story they were the most successful
bank robbers in US history but no one's
ever heard of them because they didn't
kill people they stealing millions of
dollars there's businessmen just a
complete businessman but they weren't
like you know Bonnie and Clyde shooting
up sheriff's and stuff they were just
very systematic you know businessmen so
that I was really fascinated by the
their life a crime and where they came
from they were sharecroppers from Texas
so kind of how they wanted a different
life for themselves so I'm interested in
you know that kind of person who been
left out of the system and how they kind
of justify their own crimes you know in
the system that was a TV networks
contact each other to get into that
field
oh no not too much I mean it had a super
few strange calls about you want to do a
pilot for a TV show
that's a real that's probably a much
more closed off world I yeah yeah that
that's it's amazing anything ever gets
done any you know those whatever for
good shows on TV it's amazing those even
exists if if you think there's forged
shows on
is fred allen color treadmill to
oblivion yeah I'm not much interested in
that
no just lucky to have my films are
interesting because they they have a
life that's you know their immediate
life of whatever the economics are that
someone then they have a life that's
much you know longer and more important
to me personally so you can just weather
the storm while you're making it and
keep making at me considers up lucky
sound like you got the best of all
possible worlds right now well so far I
mean I've made those sacrifices you know
if you can do without that la lifestyle
if you can take less money I mean the
word it's open if I wanted to go be a
director for hire and go do a you know
Lethal Weapon 5 and it's not that they
would really want me to do that film
anyway but you know I turned down a lot
you know every all the time but if you
want to get into that world it's waiting
for you you know once you get your
little your invites oh I haven't done
that yet there's obviously a niche for
you in Hollywood you could do you film
yeah until he can do that it seems like
you're trying to expand and going to
Europe and sort of yeah I mean this new
films it's my European arty-farty kind
of film and it really has nothing to do
with American culture or I mean it
doesn't away but it's not like pop
culture it'll disappoint people it's if
it has a strawberry strong female view
it's not a I think certain people think
I mean I've already seen it some people
saying oh you're kind of going soft on
us here what's the unit than them but
you know it's my contemplation of I
guess romance and time and you know well
as you get over you can you get over
keep making films you become my agent
you can do a new genre the old fart
family oh [ __ ] yeah well that's what the
our story kills and you can't express
everything you're thinking or who you
are in one film so well you grow and
hopefully make a lot of I admire
filmmakers who been able to you know
make these personal films up into an old
an old age yeah
so makers get better as they get older
anything mm-hmm so Rick do you feel
optimistic about independent film that
it is possible for people to make films
independently outside of Hollywood or
even within Hollywood to make your own
visions do the
it's like like it's always going on you
know I mean people can't turn that off
as much as the system as it's designed
it's kind of to suppress that sort of
individuality or I mean people sneak
through the cracks I mean I just saw a
film yesterday clerks this 27 you know a
guy made a film he's working as a clerk
you know in his own hometown his own the
actual place he worked he made a film
about life there one day in the life of
being a clerk at a convenience store you
know so people always need that to
express what's going on with them in
their own little subculture their own
little world so that'll always it always
kind of leaks through and then you have
people making personal films I think on
a much bigger level you know though well
for better words you know the Oliver
stones and Scorsese's who Spike Lee's
who are doing big films but are highly
subjective
I'd say personal visions on them so but
it's always a struggle it's never easy
but I think that system the system kind
of feeds on that newness so it kind of
needs it so there's a weird relation
like Hollywood likes that new energy new
ideas has a they like to get that and do
something standard with that so the
struggles in that that space in between
taking your new idea and making it very
traditional and conformist you know it's
like how you how you find your place in
there